[Music]
my name is Smith I'm a co-founder
outside is data really excited to be
here at data in spawn and I'm going to
talk about why relational databases can
be at the core of your data architecture
primarily I'm going to talk about some
of the technical challenges we have to
overcome to make relational databases
scale and those are our two draw handles
of this if you're going to tweet about
the talk feel free to tag us as well a
quick about me as I mentioned I am a
co-founder and currently VP engineering
at site is data prior to that I was in
Amazon in the shopping cart team when
you own the shopping cart application as
well as the backing store which was
dynamo and I'll prior to that I was in
the supply chain or an order fulfillment
is when I add Amazon siteís as I
mentioned is an open source database
it's an extension four-poster sequel
which provides distribution and
parallelization capabilities simply put
it scales out post a sequel that's a
github page so go check it out you can
download it and try it out we also have
docker and Debian and rail packages and
then feel free to star our page as well
if you guys are fans and I didn't
capture the screenshot my colleague did
all those open tabs are not today i am
manish my browser to start with why
relational databases and then our DBMS
you guys probably know this but that
stands for relational database
management systems these are your oracle
post a sequel my sequel and the like
because your architecture could be
simpler today company is a deploying
five six seven different systems one for
short term one for long term storage for
analytics for caching etc you have the
hadoo Kafka spark and then you have
plumbing to tie all these together and
there is a human cost as well in terms
of bringing people up to speed with
these systems
to set them up and and manage them but
people don't realize that relational
databases have a lot of this
functionality already built in within
them there was a benchmark by the no
sequel database a few months back where
post a sequel actually out shown the
rest of them
grando from stripe is also written blog
post apology can implement queues in
post a sequel and these just a few
examples of which show how relational
databases can be extended for various
workloads and that's because the Latian
database is actually a general purpose
data platform from front to back in
applications a lot of them are sure to
lie on relational databases whether you
have an app or website facing or LDP
application or you need back in
analytics they can't really do it all
they have fast writes both real-time and
bulk at high throughput and high
concurrency and all the time maintaining
data consistency they also have very
sophisticated query optimizers which are
dealing with for almost any workloads
and query patterns and in fact when you
start a company or a project
most the time relation it bases your
best choice
pulling Y Combinator which is a startup
accelerator the majority of startups at
YC and of choosing post a sequel as
their database of choice initially this
graph shows job postings on Hacker News
where they mentioned using a specific
technology and then shows opposed the
sequel is picking up shows and startups
that are increasing and consistently
choosing relation and specifically post
a sequel as a database of choice but if
relational databases are so great then
why do we have all these systems and I
mean most of you you know sort of know
some of the challenges we've had but you
know in the last decade as some of these
been socially mobile trends took over
there was an explosion of data right
volume of data increased we are not
talking now gigabytes we're talking
hundreds of terabytes and petabytes and
velocity of data increases as well so
we're not just John Rogers gathering and
accumulating data we need to ingest and
analyze it in real-time as well to put
it simply we needed scalable and
performance systems to support these
data trends but relational databases
don't scale right or at least that's
been the conventional wisdom when I was
at Amazon most of our applications were
built at the time in early two-thousands
on Oracle uh my sequel as a company grew
we figure out how to scale the
application and the web servers but the
database remained a bottleneck so we had
to build something new we did that by
actually taking away functionality we
took away the relational semantics and
made it a key value store we took away
sequel or the Express of query language
and provided a simple get and put API
and you also took away transactions the
data consistency
the result was dynamo which was the
precursor to no sequel movement but at
argue that it's not the relation rebuses
don't scale it said they are hard to
scale for sure when we needed them to
scale back in the early 2000s at Amazon
we didn't have the know-how or the time
to scale sequel scale transactions etc
but work and research has caught up in
the last few years and we've made you
know great strides in in tackling some
of the harder scaling problems and
relation databases so what do we need to
consider when you're talking about
scaling relational databases one how do
we take a table partition that and
actually maintain some of the relational
semantics that it all use to for example
indexes constrains foreign keys once
we've distributed data how do we run
sequel across it
especially when the sequel can be fairly
advanced and finally how do we solve
some of the hairy problems of running
transactions across nodes
especially when nodes can fail
so let's talk a little bit about scaling
the tables this probably again is you
know something you guys are mostly
familiar with but some some of the
basics of partitioning right you pick a
column and you pick a method typically
and then the simplistic but you can pick
call it more combination of the columns
or composite keys as well these are just
few examples date or ID and then there's
a you pick a method which is could be
hash or range and again there are there
are more there is more things you can do
here in terms of combinations of these
methods as well so how do we take a
large table and then split it across
lots well just break up the data and
store it in chunks right but what about
indexes or column defaults or
constraints one of the key early
insights we had was to use the
relational database as a building block
itself in this case each node here is a
relation in base itself we can then
split a large table into smaller chunks
where each chunk of the table and can
have its go on indexes and constraints
in fact when you log into a bacchanal
you can just connect to the database in
some instance on that node and then look
at some of those shots or partitions in
this case we're looking at the
campaign's table and it's a shard which
is 1 0 2 0 4 0 you can see that each
shard is just a mini version of the
original table which has its own
relational semantics what about tables
which are small and then these are your
dimensional tables reference tables for
example nation or region or continent
these might have things like date
currency or language etc we can't just
keep it on one node but in order to
joins typical patterns or to actually
replicate this table across all your
nodes allows us to push down joins and
aggregations and I'll talk a little bit
about we maintain consistency of these
replicas a little bit later
and so far we've talked about fairly
simple relation models right so you have
one large table or one large and a few
smaller tables or dimension tables but
what about complex schemas with them at
by tens or even hundreds of off tables
we can look at some of the semantics of
the data and the application itself and
realize natural partitioning dimensions
consider multi tenant application like
Salesforce I can click create an account
but I can only see my data and not in
the else's data in this case I can
consider a tenant in that system we can
partition each table by the tenant ID
and ensure that all the data belong into
that tenant is co-located in the same
node that means we cannot push down very
complex sequel because all our queries
tend to be scoped for a particular
tenant and this means we can also
support things like foreign keys in this
example we have an ads and campaigns
tables this is ad analytics as a service
as has a foreign key to campaigns which
means a car in certain art which is not
belong to a campaign this allows us to
lean on database to enforce some of
these application constraints because
each campaign an ad is owned by the
company or the tenant we can add the
tenant ID as part of the foreign key we
now know that all the data belong to the
tenant lives in the same node and we can
enforce the small key constraint without
having to look up data across every node
so the key for us was using the
relational base as a building block each
worker node is relational base itself
allows us to maintain indexes
constraints column defaults on each node
also by understanding some of the cement
semantics of the application we can
scale complex relational models while
maintaining some of the
interdependencies between them with
multi tenant applications for example
choosing the tenant ID as a partition
column allows us to maintain foreign key
relationships between them and allows
applications to migrate with minimal
changes so not that we've partitioned
the data let's talk about scaling sequel
so there are a few things that happen
inside the database when you type in a
sequel query 1 there is a parser which
takes us and converse at into a tree of
relational algebra operators there is a
planner which takes this tree generates
multiple possible plans and it takes the
best one based on certain cost and the
finally the executor execute it in this
case select translates to a project
operator the where Clause translates to
a filter operation or relational algebra
operator f of X can be an expression
like x greater than 100 you can have
join operators and then the from clause
basically denotes the relation we are
scanning from so how do these actually
map to distributed data so the main
fundamental relation logical operator we
need to introduce is the collect
operator or also known as the gather
operator essentially what it does is
reconstitute all the shards into an on
to separate form so in this case collect
basically collects all the shards or one
hour two and so on and we get back our
original amount distributed relation
so now that we have introduced this
operator how can we use this in concert
with other operators we can use some
algebraic properties to optimize these
plans the first one we look at is the
commutative property in mathematical
terms this means a plus B equals B plus
C it doesn't matter in which order we
apply these operations so let's look at
how we can use this let's say I'm
selecting a column X from a disability
table the plan on the left is our first
initial plan I can introduce a collect
operator gather all the shards onto one
node and then select the column but I
can actually commute these two
operations and then first select the
column from each shot and collect only
that column on to the coordinator both
plans are equivalent but the plan the
right is going to be much more efficient
especially if you have very wide tables
you can also look at the distributive
property again the mathematical terms
this basically means I can distribute
the the multiplication across the
addition and how we can use it let's
look at if you are joining two large
tables or to disability tables again the
plan on the left is our original non-jew
plan right so I can first collect both
distribute tables onto one node and then
just perform the join but under certain
scenarios I can distribute the join
across the collect operator and what are
the scenarios well we talked about some
of it a few slides back for example if
I'm joining with a small or dimension
table or if my data is co-located and
I'm joining on the 10-8 ID in this case
now we can perform the join on each
worker node and an only collect that is
also to join
we can also look at the associative
property in this case if I'm adding a
few numbers it doesn't matter in which
order I add them I can ID plus B first
and not that to C or I can add B plus C
and then add that to a and you know very
simply I can use that to paralyze my
aggregates in this case some so instead
of collecting the data and then
calculating the sum I can sum the
columns on each worker node collect the
sums and then sum the sounds on the
coordinator this is again a simplistic
example for average for example you will
do a sum and count for others you can
consider things like approximation
algorithms as well so let's look at an
example query so here I have a query I'm
doing a join with a small table I have a
few filter clauses and also applications
this is my original non distributed tree
of relational operators so I have Nagre
gate I've converted these into specific
operators have a project a filter and
the join across those two tables a quick
aside on how Ashley relational databases
execute these this called the volcano
style or a iterator model essentially
the topmost node calls next couple and
then that called cascades down the tree
down to join which then scans the data
and then the data basically flows from
the bottom to the top this is a first
iteration for the plan in the
description format essentially we can
just slap the collect operation on top
of these tables and the rest of the plan
on top essentially remains unchanged
but this is expensive cause we expect
these tables to be to be large here are
some of the optimizations that we we do
one we've pushed down the filters and
projections below the join itself why is
this important well imagine if you're
joining tables with billions of rows
typically what relational databases will
do is sort both these tables and then
merge them but if I can filter a
majority of rows the planner can
actually choose for optimized plans for
example keeping one relation in memory
and then doing either has to loop or
hash joins review some of our algebraic
properties we talked about example Hamid
is an associate properties to push down
the projections in this case you've also
amended the project with the join column
which is an important note because now
we can also not just push them down but
actually modify operators to push them
down and we've paralyzed the aggregate
as well so this is what the
transformation actually looks like for
the relational algebra tree the
important thing to note is that we've
pulled up the collect further up the the
tree which means that you're pushing
down computation to the worker nodes
before we need to collect the data onto
one single node this means better
parallelization and better performance
but how do we actually execute this
relation algebra a tree well similar to
the way we can take sequel and convert
that into relational algebra we can go
the other way as well so we can take a
tree or fragments of the tree and
convert that back into sequel in this
case we can take everything below the
collect operator convert that into a
sequel fragment and run that on the
worker nodes and then everything on will
above the the collect node and run that
on the coordinator and as we noted
before each worker node is actually just
a sequel database so we can run these
fragments natively on the worker nodes
and crucially each worker node can then
do its own secondary optimization which
is picking the right indexes or choosing
the right join methods so the key was
carrying sequel for us really was
introducing new relational algebra
operators for distributed processing
allows us to construct the problem into
his basic theoretical form and reason
about the interactions between these and
existing operators as well this gives us
the confidence that our optimizer can
generate sound plans we can also
introduce new operators like map and
reduce for example if our data is not
co-located and we want to do a
repartition joy' relation databases half
primitives which allows us to introduce
these operators Trimble's to write two
files or tables primitives to move data
between nodes and to apply objective
computational data as well
so let's talk about we've talked about
you know partition data and then
paralyzing sequel across some of these
tables but when more complex problems we
run into this transactions will span
multiple nodes or multiple partitions
and if you commit in one place how do we
make sure we commit everywhere or if you
roll back a transaction how do we roll
back everywhere let's use the canonical
you know money transfer in example so in
this case I'm transferring money between
two accounts I want to make sure this
happens atomically in the transaction
and then let's say I'm a big back right
so I can't fit all the return to one
node in this case we started by a count
ID and so Alice and Bob's account
actually live on different nodes so
these commands get issued to the
coordinator first let's assume Alice's
data on the first node and Bob's data
lives on the second node
so the coordinator first issues a begin
transaction come on to node one it
decrements data from Alice's account so
at this point can we commit this
transaction on node one not yet because
what if not to has failed at this point
then we'd have deduct later but not
added to Alice's account so let's keep
the transaction open and issue a second
one for Bob's count now the update bob
that account so now can we commit well
not yet because even though we have an
open transaction on both nodes node one
might have crashed at this point so we
could have committed on node two but
then you've lost a transaction on node
one so how do we solve this we actually
need to do this in multiple phases or
two phases and commonly known as
two-phase commit and again this is
probably something you guys have already
heard of the first this is the first
interesting phase now which is a prepare
phase where we prepare the transaction
for commit there are few things wrapped
in here so let's dive into that two
things happen then you should prepare
come on one it stores the state of the
transaction on this on durable store
such that it be it can be committed or
aborted at a later time even if the
machinery starts and then two it holds
the locks and the rules such as no the
transaction can modify the balance until
the two PC commits robots
and what happens if a node fails during
the parfaits well we haven't committed
the transaction anywhere so we can just
issue rollbacks and go back to the vivo
but in order to progress to the next
phase the coordinator has to make sure
that it gets back a preparer success
from every node and that means doing
those two things that we talked about
only after this can the coordinate to
move on to the next phase of the
two-phase commit and this is the commit
phase where we now actually go in and
try to commit this prepare transaction
in this case what happens if the node
fails and we've actually committed the
transaction one load well remember that
we've stored the state of this
transaction on disk so when the node
comes back up the coordinator can go in
and then commit the transaction or if it
didn't succeed roll back that
transaction if the node is permanently
gone then we can promote a replica and
commit the two PC on that pellagra but
assuming no failures we've come to the
transaction IV node essentially the
two-phase commit we guarantee the
transaction will either succeed on every
node or fail on every node to PC allows
us to handle failures while preserving
the atomicity
of transactions and by building a
dispute relation database then each node
itself is a database the nodes can
handle concurrent modifications and
correctly enforce constraints so that we
cannot overspend and poster stress is
actually by taking row level locks
but we also have a bottle deadlocks as
we mentioned before post a sequel
ensures consistency on a single node by
taking dual level locks but this can
also cause deadlocks that complex and
concurrent transactions deadlocks can be
concerned these have to be solved before
you can handle workflows of increasing
complexity and scale if not trans will
remain hanging until kill by the
application and your throughput will
reduce so let's walk through how this
would happen again the same money
transfers an example a session one comes
along and updates the Ballet's for Alice
in this case poster Sybil takes the role
of a lock on the row for Alice session 2
comes along and updates a balance for
Bob it acquires a roll of lock for the
row for Bob at this point nothing is
wrong and no one is waiting on anybody
else session 1 then tries to update the
row for Bob but it cannot do so because
session 2 holds a lot for that row so
session one waits waiting for the lock
to be released session 2 then comes
along and tries to update the row for
Alice and it cannot do so because
session one holds a lock for that row
now both sessions are waiting in touch
waiting on each other and we are
deadlocked no progress can be made at
this point so you would ask like don't
relational databases already solve this
well they do and the way they do that is
actually construct a directed graph of
the sessions or transactions in this
case each node in this graph is a
transaction and each directed edge
repins that transaction waiting on
another one for a lock now you can run
standard cycle detection algorithms in
this graph this is a simplistic example
obviously but you can imagine a more
complex knowledge with tens or hundreds
of transactions
when the cycle is detected you know
there is deadlock and you can make the
decision to kill one of these in order
to make progress but does that work in
the disturber environments this actually
shows what a deadlock would look like in
the distributor database if you look at
any individual machine in this picture
there is no deadlock on node one session
two weights on session one but it
doesn't seem to be blocked or anything
else suppose the sequence deadlock
detection is not going to work by only
looking information on one node you need
a disputed deadlock detector we need to
associate each session with a global
unique transaction identifier the global
did a deadlock detector then dumps these
weight graphs from each node and
constructs a global lock weight graph on
the coordinator we can now look for
seconds in this graph and in this case
we decided to kill the session - so the
session one can make progress so we've
seen that scaling transactions needs to
PC and in table detection allows us to
maintain correctness and scale do
multiple sessions running complex
transactions we haven't touched on some
of the benefits that a single node
relational database gets us for example
MVCC which gives us concurrency on a
single node as well as as well as
isolation we also haven't touched on
failure handling that much you can use
things like a four-pack source to create
highly wearable replicas of clusters but
relational databases come with a rich
set of replication and Aicha
capabilities allowing you to configure
application across various nodes in
various topologies
so how do we we've talked about scaling
tables scaling sequel by ODIs relational
algebra and transactions by two PC enter
log detection how do we implement all of
this without spending another twenty
years building a relationship this from
scratch the answer for us really was
disposed a sequel post a sequel has a
very modular code base this has led to a
lot of folks of it
for example redshift is a fork of post
stress from several versions back as was
greenplum
this modularity was later formalized and
commoditized in the form of extension
appears you can now replace any parts of
the query execution pipeline from the
planet of a spots of the executors for
example you can change the storage
storage mechanism using the foreign
tables API and we did that to add
columns of storage or you can use the
transaction callbacks to provide some of
the distribution distributed transaction
guarantees that we need and we've noted
various points reusing post the sequel
as a building block site is an extension
which provides some of the distribution
paralyzation features so not only are we
using it as a building block across
various nodes but even on a single node
we can intercept parts of the of the
query execution pipeline and rely on
Postgres to perform at the paths for
example query parsing
and that's because suppose the sequel is
not just a database but it's an
ecosystem psychosis is the distribution
layer in this ecosystem that extension
is like posters which is one of the
largest geospatial libraries out there
poster sequel also has a JSON B which is
a binary JSON type fully indexable for
fast lookup it has things like full-text
search custom type sniper gates listen
order feminism's and so much more and
what this means is that post sequel can
be extended into an all-purpose dispute
relational database you can take these
extensions and features and mix and
match them to adapt post a sequel to
your use case if your data was small
enough you could always do that on a
single node beside us now you can
display the data and paralyze your
queries the scaling to your future date
on Ian's posess has been in development
for about 20 years but the development
is ramping up in Postgres then he got
features like parallel queries logical
replication and decorative partitioning
and there's much more in posters level
when the need to scale arose with the
rise of web social and mobile networks
there was no time to implement some of
the functionality of relational
databases no secret was born but his
applications of become more advanced so
have relational databases
Postgres in particular allows you to
deploy a scalable extensible open source
relational database with disabilities
and disability action z'
across both unstructured and structured
data of any size there's a feature of
indeed architecture might just be one
big poster s cluster thank you do
understand right that to get all of
those nice features on top of Postgres
features were able to do it with
existing extensions and just combine
them in the right way yeah so site
itself as an extension of coarseness
equal so we don't focus as equal so we
stay up to date you can be installed
with sequel ad situs so you get all the
features of Postgres and then cite us
provides the distribution and
paralyzation features as well do you
have the anywhere published a specific
recipe for like the you know to break
down the features which you described
and what would be the extensions to do
it or is it just all the what you had on
the slide so via not so we provide one
extension not all extensions are
provided by us so there's an ecosystem
right so I think that is a website
called PG extension below that which
which has a list of all the extensions
available and the kind of features they
provide as well it was last question
Thanks so have you tried to pinch mark
using some kind of like standard things
such as TP CH or let's say for
transaction T PCE yes actually if you go
to our our documentation we have
instructions on on some of the
benchmarks so you can actually run those
meter like the instructions currently
have PG bench so you can run PG bench
and compare that to sort of regular
single posters as well for queries what
we typically see is in on a single node
we are limited by posts equals
performance and giving but because we
parallelize that we sort of scale
linearly as you add CPU cores and
machines
you